so gabriel sterling is the voting
implementation manager with the
georgia secretary of state's office and
he has had enough of trump
and went off yesterday during a public
statement
telling donald trump that he's gone too
far
that election workers are being
threatened and
targeted in georgia thanks to the things
donald trump has been saying
and that donald trump must stop
inspiring his followers to be violent
right away check out these videos and
again this is rep
lifelong republican gabriel sterling
who works for the republican georgia
secretary of state saying
trump has gone too far and he is
complicit in the harassment and
targeting of poll workers
and other election workers in the state
of georgia
it has all gone too
far
all of it
genova today asked for chris krebs ace
patriot who ran sissa
to be shot a 20-something tech in
gwinnett county today
has death threats and a noose put out
saying he should be hung for treason
because he was transferring a report on
batches
from an ems to a county computer so he
could read it
it has to stop
mr president you have not condemned
these actions or this language
senators you have not condemned this
language or these actions
never might mean he says trump hasn't
condemned it trump has encouraged
it we're like a few layers removed uh
certainly there hasn't been condemnation
because donald trump has been
encouraging this behavior and again just
a reminder
this is a lifelong conservative
republican
gabriel sterling voting implementation
manager with the secretary of state in
the state of georgia georgia of course
one of the states that donald trump
lost to joe biden but insists
that he actually won let's see a little
bit more video here
as the secretary said yesterday people
aren't giving you the best advice what's
actually going on the ground
it's time to look forward if you want to
run free election
in four years fine do it but everything
we're
seeing right now there's not a path
be the bigger man here and stop step in
tell your supporters don't be violent
don't intimidate all that's wrong is
un-american
the republican party owns the crazy
right now
but when you have one guy like this who
says
enough is enough he instantly gets
attacked by trumpists
here is gabriel sterling essentially
explaining stochastic terrorism i don't
he doesn't he's not using this term and
i don't think he even recognizes that
he's doing it but
he's he's effectively doing it when
gabriel sterling
says some people because trump has so
many people that listen to him
some people will hear the stuff he says
and someone could do something violent
on donald trump say so check it out
and you know there are people who can be
have some righteous intonation to be
angry
but there's also people out there at
this point in the social media world we
see what happens
there are some nut balls out there who
are going to take this thing the
president told me to do this
essentially you have to be responsible
you have to be responsible in your
rhetoric you have to be responsible in
your statements
you have to be responsible in your deeds
that shouldn't be too much to ask for
people who ask
for us to give them responsibility this
is really the crux
of stochastic terrorism which is the
idea that
given a big enough audience it starts to
become
likely and probable that
if a media figure plants a certain idea
in the minds of their audience if
there's
you know if you attack someone every day
on your show
and your audience is 100 people
it's not super likely that your attacks
will motivate anybody to actually go
and try to kill that person as an
example but if your audience is a
million
or 10 million or you know 80 million as
trump's audience is on twitter
including certainly some bots but okay
80 million roughly
uh even if it's only a one in 80 million
chance that somebody will hear what you
say and go and attack someone
once you have 80 million people that are
listening to what you say that starts to
become probable and likely and that's
essentially what gabriel sterling is
referring to here and of course he's
absolutely correct he's saying the right
thing
now at the same time gabriel sterling
has been part of the machine in georgia
that has been suppressing the vote in
ways
republicans believe are advantageous
trying to suppress the non-white vote
trying to suppress the non-rich vote for
a long time
and you've got a lot of people now
holding up gabriel sterling as some kind
of hero
because look he republican takes on
trump right now as far as we know he's
taking on trump because his friends are
poll workers and it's all about
protecting his friends and it's not
really about running fair elections
i don't know one way or or the other but
the point is
he's saying the right thing in this
instance he may be saying it for the
right reasons he may not
but georgia is one of the worst places
in the country as far as voter
suppression is concerned
and sterling's been part of it for a
long time he's been part of it
as a a worker as an employee of the
secretary of state's office
he was previously a right-wing
councilman in georgia so as much as he's
not trying
to stop a problem he's identified
he's been a part of the problem for a
very very long time broken clocks
can still be right every once in a while
i think this is one of those examples
trump doesn't care
and he immediately this guy becomes
enemy number one for the trumpists who
believe
because trump keeps saying it and some
fox news hosts keep saying it and so
do others for the people that believe
trump really did win
joe biden really did steal this thing
this isn't going to make a difference
but needless to say it's very
interesting to watch